[Musique]
depuis le mois de mai dernier
l'emblématique rue de rivoli à paris
s'est trouvé une nouvelle vocation de la
bastille à la concorde
les cyclistes y sont rois seuls les
autobus et les taxis il conserve une
voie pour circuler ça a tout changé
c'est vraiment beaucoup plus facile un
plan
or voilà on n'y a plus de place pour les
voitures j'ai laissé ma moto au garage
donc maintenant mon celle vélo la rue de
rivoli fait partie de quelques 50
kilomètres additionnels de pistes
cyclables mis en place à la hâte à la
fin du confinement et corona piste où
paris et pour les cyclistes mais
maintenant oui c'est comme ça j'en
profite ce sur mais bon cela comme un
peu difficile de circuler pour les
voitures et paris n'est pas seul partout
dans les communes qui ceinturent la
ville lumière des grenats piste ont
aussi fait leur apparition dans l'esprit
français jusqu'à il ya peu le vélo
c'était pas un transport met au sport
c'est un loisir c'était une mobilité
douce c'est gentil c'est pour s'amuser
de dimanche mais en fait aujourd'hui le
vélo est en train de devenir un moyen de
transport à part entière
steinman au sterenn en quelque sorte le
vélo dans son adn
le hollandais d'origine crois que la
pandémie a permis à l'hexagone de
rattraper un énorme retard notamment en
accélérant la construction du réseau rer
b dans les banlieues parisiennes
ça veut dire réseau express régional
vélo hervé en fait c'est un réseau
cyclable pour la région ile de france et
donc on se dit mais pourquoi n'aurions
nous pas un réseau de routes comme les
voitures
et comme les trains avec le rail et
s'adonner réseau de 650 km consistant en
neuf ans neuf pistes qui aujourd'hui
vont être réalisés dans notre région
sans l'arrivée de ces corridors protégés
et le leader fiac n'aurait pas le
courage de faire le trajet vers son
travail plein coeur de paris
ça change tout c'est du gip eu de stress
à partir moi j'ai trois enfants
ça y est mes enfants font du vélo à
châtillon machine va au collège à vélo
c'était pas le cadre je pense qu'il ya
un
c'est l'effet de masse du cycliste là où
elle était seule sur la route ces vols
avaient peur aujourd'hui elles sont
quatre copines elles vont au collège
ensemble à vélo
l'engouement pour le vélo est elle à
paris qu'on constate depuis l'an passé
une augmentation de plus de 60% de
cyclistes dans les rues et si on le sait
c'est que la ville a installé des
compteurs de vélos des bornes
on les appelle les totems où on peut
voir par exemple que pour aujourd'hui
rue de rivoli on en est à plus de 8700
cycliste et on met à l'heure de pointe
le soir on a urgé là gît dans
l'improvisation la cohérence les
idéologies qui bouge on se défend bien
d'être anti vélo mais le maire du xvème
arrondissement de paris est ulcérée par
l'apparition courant du mois d'août
d'une piste cyclable à double sens à
deux pas de la mairie
nous sommes dans une situation où les
cyclistes risquent leur vie ou la rue de
vaugirard est embouteillée en permanence
ce qui crée évidemment une pollution
supplémentaire parce que les véhicules à
l'arrêt polluent les livraisons se font
de part et d'autre et souvent dans le
couloir de bus parce qu'il ya également
un couloir de bus de l'autre côté de la
voie
donc les les camions souvent s'arrête
dans cette partie de la rue parce qu'ils
peuvent pas aller dans la piste cyclable
et où nous avons difficultés de
fonctionnement même pour les services
municipaux pour toutes les critiques
kelly suis régulièrement de la part des
automobilistes des élus ou des
commerçants la maire de paris anne
hidalgo n'a pas l'intention de faire
demi tour
elle vient tout juste d'annoncer que les
core 1 à piste seront pérennisés au delà
la pandémie il s'est marié ève bédard
radio canada